hey youtubers is Charlie so Game of
Thrones had so much WTF it totally went
there we get to see a couple new
characters for the first time and we got
two of our big you know major season
four events so just a quick reminder
around to the giveaway starts now all
you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment below on
this video so because there's so much to
talk about from the episode let's just
get right in it I'm gonna do my top 5
WTF moments and then my review so
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
anything yet but here we go number 5
Ramsay snow takes Theon and heads for
moat Cailin this is a little different
from the books but essentially Ramsay is
trying to get recognized as an official
heir of the dreadfort in order to do
that he has to take moat Cailin in the
north it's going to bring them closer to
Theon sister and her force of Ironborn
so it seems like they're setting them up
for a big battle between the flayed men
in the Ironborn later this season think
of it as like a slightly less epic
version of the fight that's coming
between the wildlings and the Nights
Watch I thought it was interesting that
Theon had just found out about the red
wedding for the first time and I have to
give a bonus shout out to the hunting
scene at the beginning those two women
you saw both one shooting the bow and
the one being shot were the women that
Ramsay used to torture Theon with sex
last season number four the jousting
dwarves at the purple wedding everyone
had been asking me if the show is going
to use them since they were such a
defining moment from the wedding banquet
in the books but I had no idea and was
just as surprised as everyone else
whenever they came pouring out of the
lion's mouth as messed up as it was just
to degrade the dwarves by making them
play act the War of the five kings did
you see the looks of horror and rage on
everyone's faces even Tywin was pissed
off but it was Lady Alana's face that
was the best the Queen of thorns just
pure dagger shooting out of her eyes I
didn't see any dwarves that resembled
penny but if you thought you spotted
just let me know in the comments below
because she's actually a pretty big
character in the book the music that
played under all of this was the rains
of castamere if you didn't hear it right
away there were a few different versions
of it throughout the wedding some with
lyrics and some that was just the music
itself but it was playing in the chapel
during the ceremony when the singers
came out later then during the jousting
and during Joffrey's death scene I will
say that I thought the most disturbing
dwarf jousting moment was when the one
was just mounting the wolf's head skull
at the end and Sansa was just looking on
that was when the rains of castamere
just swelled up underneath and it got
really really depressing and sad number
three brand wargs with the weirwood tree
and sees everything it was hard to tell
but bran was actually seeing everything
that the where woods had seen all over
the planet that's why he could see the
north and King's Landing
he also saw a side shot of the green
seer who gave him instructions on how to
find him everyone keeps asking me if
cold hands is gonna appear and we might
find out next week I was also super
excited to finally get an answer about
the dragon flying over King's Landing
brand saw it as it happened in the past
so I'm gonna be optimistic and say he
was seeing one of the great Targaryen
dragons maybe it could have been
balerion the black dread it's hard to
tell just from the shadow but he was the
biggest drag in recorded history
number two Joffrey degrades everyone at
the banquet it takes real talent to be
that awful I was actually surprised that
he didn't pick on Sansa more but if
Tyrion hadn't have been there he
probably would have if it wasn't clear
they were really just trying to show
that Tyrion of all the people there had
the most reason to want Joffrey dead
everyone at the feast saw him defy
Joffrey inside Joffrey just you know
completely degrade him so regardless of
how Joffrey died and who was responsible
Tyrion is going to be taking the blame
for now I will say that one of my
favorite Joffrey lines from the episode
and there were several amazing ones was
there has been entirely too much
amusement here today but here we go on
to the big time my number one WTF moment
Joffrey dies the most amazingly horrible
death if it wasn't clear he choked to
death the poison was called the
strangler because choking of course and
when it's made it actually looks purple
that's why this is called the purple
wedding because Joffrey is killed with
purple poison the show hasn't really
fully explained how he was poisoned or
who's responsible I mean they want us to
think Tyrion did it but I'm not gonna go
all CSI and kind of explain everything
just because it would be a little bit
spoilery so I'll save that for a future
video the interesting thing that I think
we can take away is that Tyrion might
not be guilty he was actually really
confused whenever he picked that gobble
it up at the end and was staring at
Joffrey's dead corpse so he really has
no idea what happened and did you catch
the shot of Lady Olenna whenever he
grabbed that goblet for Joffrey a few
moments earlier she wasn't staring
daggers anymore the death scene itself
was amazing I didn't count but they cut
back to his
face several times in the camera
lingered they want you to enjoy the
moment but also be disturbed at the same
time it was a lot of fun to watch
Joffrey suffer horribly because he died
a very slow death but I will have a hard
time enjoying it just because that final
shot of his face is just so awful
looking so now it's your turn let me
know what were all your WTF moments from
the episode and what was your reaction
to the Joffrey death scene there was
this really interesting thing that
george RR martin said he mourns his
villains just as much as he mourns
killing heroes just like you would mourn
a real person he explained that as bad
as they are
villains serve a purpose in the story
and once they're gone they're really
hard to replace so the next big question
we need to ask is who's going to replace
Joffrey's role in the story as most
hated character that is I nominate
Ramsay snow but leave your suggestions
in the comments below if you think
there's someone more evil than Ramsay
overall I gave the episode a solid a
game of Thrones has the best sets and
the best costumes and we have to
acknowledge the music the way they kept
using the rains of castamere was just so
haunting even if you didn't know Joffrey
was going to die in the episode the
music just made you feel creepy and
weird throughout like the universe did
not want this wedding to be a success
they also did this really awesome thing
with the set design in every single
banquet shot there's an image of a lion
in the background somewhere wherever the
camera turns my favorite one was the
shot where it looked like the lion was
eating lorises head as for character
development I just love how Roose treats
Ramsay you know he may be the most evil
person in the world but he's still his
son and he gives him a chance to earn
his name I do want to mention though
that when Ramsay and Locke were talking
about cutting Jaime's hand off it was
almost more evil than when the dwarf was
mounting that wolf's head Lady Olenna
and Tywin scenes were amazing as always
two of the best actors on the show and
just rich with foreshadowing don't you
wonder though will Tywin ever have any
fun before he dies I'm actually kind of
wondering that also who knew that Cersei
would be jealous of Brienne
despite kind of dumping Jaime last week
it kind of seems like Cersei doesn't
want anyone to be happy but on the more
positive end of things I really love the
direction Brandt's character is going
you know he's slowly just trying to
completely leave his body so that he can
be whole again I can't wait to see what
his scenes with the three-eyed Raven are
like let me know what your final
thoughts are
the episode and now that the most hated
character is gone who do you think is
going to fill that role you know if not
on the Iron Throne then somewhere else
in the world evil abhors a vacuum
so obviously someone's going to have to
rise to the occasion I'm kind of
thinking it's gonna be Ramsay so in
related news I'll be posting my Q&A
video tomorrow where I'll announce the
week two winner all you have to do to
participate in that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video my
next bonus video will probably be a
Bloodraven you know greenseer video
unless something more interesting comes
along feel free to leave suggestions for
that in the comments too but right now
you can click here to get that Q&A I'll
add the annotation as soon as I post it
and you can click here to get my bonus
purple wedding video I just explained
the wedding itself at a little bit more
detail so thank you so much for watching
this was so epic high fives everyone see
you tomorrow